C'est normal de se sentir
dépassé par les événements. Si
vous vivez des moments
difficiles, parler à quelqu'un,
aller chercher de l'aide. Vous
n'êtes jamais seul.
On traverse Tours sur une
période difficile et c'est
justifié d'être anxieux. Si vous
avez de la misère, vous avez des
difficultés, parler aux gens
autour de vous, dit aux gens que
vous êtes là pour. En tant que
Canadiens, nous serons tous
épaule à épaule ensemble,
aujourd'hui, demain est
toujours.
- Nous avons tous été attristés
par les événements de la fin de
semaine dernière. Plusieurs
personnes merveilleuses sont
disparues et à mesure que le
temps passe, nous apprenons de
plus en plus qui ils étaient et
ce qu'ils faisaient.
Ils laissent derrière eux des
familles qui sont en deuil et
qui ont le coeur brisé.
Nous voulons aussi reconnaître
les premiers répondants qui ont
réagi sur les premières lignes
et leur action nous rappelle
qu'il y a plusieurs citoyens qui
mettent en danger leur vie pour
protéger le public.
Tragiquement, ne Constable de la
GRC à payer le prix ultime en
faisant son devoir.
Le fait que les gens de la
Nouvelle-Écosse se sont unis
pour offrir le soutien et la
compassion. La solidarité lors
des périodes difficiles et
caractéristiques de cette
province. La lueur d'espoir de
cette tragédie c'est que les
gens de la Nouvelle-Écosse
Santini en offrant leur appui et
leur compassion. L'esprit de
corps en cette période difficile
et caractéristique de notre
province. Cet espoir et les
familles des victimes peuvent
être réconfortées à savoir que
les gens de la Nouvelle-Écosse
sont derrière devant cette
période difficile.
(cornemuse)
- Bonjour, mon nom est Jonathan
Torrens, je suis un membre fier
de cette communauté. Comme vous
pouvez vous imaginer, les gens
ici ont beaucoup de misère à
comprendre quelque chose qui est
dénudé de sens. C'est comme s'il
y a des millions de questions
mais aucune réponse. Tellement
de douleurs et de tristesse,
pourquoi est-ce qu'on doit dire
au revoir aux gens que vous
connaissez? Aujourd'hui, c'est
le frère de quelqu'un, l'ami, le
fils, les enfants ou les parents
de quelqu'un qui a disparu.
Normalement dans une communauté
comme la nôtre, dans une petite
ville, on se connecte, en scène
et c'est quelque chose comme ça
arrive, on se rassemble ou en ça
aide, on est là pour s'appuyer
et partager des souvenirs, de la
douleur. Des pleurs. Et on ne
peut pas faire ça maintenant.
C'est pour ça qu'on est ici
aujourd'hui, par quelques
résidents clients une idée que
les familles et la communauté
devait savoir que vous n'êtes
pas seul, même si vous êtes dans
un sens, vous n'êtes pas seul.
Même si on ne peut pas
pleinement comprendre votre
douleur, on est ici pour trouver
une façon d'apporter un peu du
deuil et de vous aider. Les gens
doivent savoir qu'à travers le
monde ils ont l'impression que
vous êtes là pour les aider.
C'est ce qui les aide à
perdurer. Merci pour ça. Il y a
une tradition dans cette partie
demande, quand il n'y a pas de
mots, on utilise la chanson et
c'est de ça dont il s'agit.
Essayer de trouver un peu de
temps pour se remémorer.
- Mes chers concitoyens de la
Nouvelle-Écosse, nous sommes ici
avec vous, nous sommes en deuil.
Votre esprit bienveillant sera
avec nous. On ne vous laissera
pas tomber. Le pays est avec
vous, en esprit, avec de l'amour
et avec de la musique. Je vous
aime, nous vous aimons tous, je
vous remercie de tous les
cadeaux que vous m'avez donnés à
travers les années. Vous êtes
des gens très forts, vous
resterez très fort. Je veux
jouer une pièce pour vous que
j'ai choisi parce que ça vient
d'une belle performance que j'ai
vu il y a quelques jours qui a
été joué par une des victimes
qui étaient une violoniste. Je
voulais sa performance et jouer
cette pièce pour tous ceux qui
pour tous ceux qui alors ta
contribution à la fête ont perdu
♪ ♪ ♪
♪ ♪ ♪♪ ♪ ♪
- c'est difficile de trouver les
mots, comment est-ce qu'on
comprend quelque chose qui est
dénudé d'instance, pour les
familles, vous avez perdu
beaucoup et en s'en excuse. Vous
êtres chers étaient importants,
ils avaient des rêves et ont
contribué à la province et nous
sommes tous ici pour se rappeler
et que vous sachiez que vous
n'êtes pas seul. Cette province
sera derrière vous à mesure que
vous essayez de reprendre la vie
normale et comme premier
ministre je veux vous dire :
faites en sorte de prendre soin
de vous, sachez que vous êtes
aimé. Pour les communautés, vous
savez que c'est une communauté
merveilleuse. Ce qui est arrivé
ici ce n'est pas qui nous somme.
Ça va nous changer un petit peu
peut-être mais ça ne nous
définit pas. Alors continuons à
faire ça ensemble. Les gens de
notre province, on est plus fort
ensemble.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Bonsoir, tout le monde,
Jennifer et moi on a le coeur
brisé et dévasté. Tellement les
familles nos prières et nos
pensées sont avec vous et on est
ici.
Pour vous.
♪ ♪ ♪
♪ ♪ ♪♪ ♪ ♪
- Bonjour, je suis Lenore Zann,
membre du Parlement, et je peux
dire que ça été une semaine très
difficile pour nous tous ici
Cumberland, dimanche matin, on
s'est levé avec cette horreur,
cet acte dénudé de tout sens,
cet acte de violence incroyable
et malheureusement, on a depuis
découvert que de plus en plus de
gens sont disparus. Leur vie a
été coupée et mon coeur et avec
tous ceux qui ont perdu un être
cher, aux collections travailler
avec quelqu'un qui disparut, et
aux amis qui ont perdu quelqu'un
qu'ils aimaient. Il parle
d'aller médiation, c'est une
période difficile avec la
distanciation physique, c'est
une période difficile, pour être
en deuil. Mais je pense que ce
soir, on voit que rien ne peut
nous arrêter de s'appuyer, les
uns les autres, en tant que gens
de la Nouvelle-Écosse canadien.
- Bonjour, mon nom est Barry
Bebee, je suis pasteur, de deux
endroits la tuerie de la fête,
ma femme Linda et moi nous somme
très endeuillé. On est en deuil
avec les gens de nos
communautés, toute la perte et
la douleur et le coeur brisé et
le dimanche matin, c'était le
choc total qui est tombé sur
nous quand on a témoigné de ces
événements tragiques et on ne
peut que se demander pourquoi,
dans ces communautés, dans cette
belle province, pourquoi c'est
arrivé. Ensuite on a vécu
beaucoup de peine et de douleur
quand on a entendu parler de
tous ceux qui sont disparus,
tous ceux qui ont souffert la
perte de leur famille et c'est
le lundi que j'ai commencé à me
sentir, j'avais honte qu'un être
humain agirait comme ça avec
autant de malice et de cruauté
et de brutalité. J'ai en qu'un
être humain agisse comme ça.
Maintenant on cinquièmement mais
on ne sait pas pourquoi. Mais je
crois que nous savons ce qu'on
devrait faire. Nous devrions
être proches les uns des autres
de manière responsable et
réconforter ceux en deuil et
encourager, appuyer les familles
et nos communautés et nos
policiers et nos chefs au
gouvernement qui doive composer
avec tout ça. Il faut s'aider
les uns les autres, et aussi
être prêt de Dieu.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Bonjour tout le monde. En
cette période très difficile, on
a besoin instinctif de nous
rassembler et c'est ce qu'on
fait ce soir, du mieux qu'on
peut. Nous nous rassemblons
parce que on veut que ces gens
qui ont perdu leur famille et
leurs amis, à quel point on est
préoccupé pour eux, à quel point
on les aime et on veut que le
dossier de la GRC et tous les
gens sur les premières lignes
sachent qu'on respecte ce qu'ils
font et qu'on est reconnaissant
pour tout ce qu'ils font pour
nous. Sachez que vous êtes tous
dans notre coeur.
- Voici une chanson que j'ai
écrit il y a des années sur
comment survivre.
♪ ♪ ♪
- aujourd'hui, je veux vous
parler de communauté. C'est la
communauté où j'ai grandi. C'est
la communauté qui est chez moi
et si la communauté à laquelle
j'appartiens et que je
représente depuis 14 ans
maintenant.
C'est une communauté de gens
travaillant qui aime s'amuser,
bienveillante. Des familles qui
se préoccupent de leur
communauté et de leurs amis et
membres de leur famille. Nous
sommes dans une communauté
profondément endeuillée en
douleur.
Mais ça ne doit pas nous
ensevelir. Nous devons montrer
qu'on est résiliant, qu'on est
fort comme communauté. Nous
unir. Faisons en sorte de
célébrer la vie de ceux qui sont
perdus. Célébrant leur
contribution à notre communauté.
Ils ont fait en sorte que ce
soit un meilleur endroit pour
nous tous.
Rappelons-nous qu'ensemble, nous
sommes meilleurs.
♪ ♪ ♪
- j'ai grandi là-bas. J'ai été
finissant.
Et j'ai été profondément touché
par ce qui est arrivé. La fin de
semaine dernière chez moi.
Et la partie de la planète qui a
formé mon caractère. Je suis
revenu ici après 30 ans et
j'essayais de revenir chez moi
depuis 20 ans maintenant. Et pas
seulement parce que c'est très
bot ici au niveau géographie,
mais si les gens de la Nouvelle-
Écosse qui me manquait. Et c'est
pour ça que ce qui est arrivé en
fin de semaine m'a vraiment fait
mal comme nous tous parce que je
connais le genre de personne à
qui c'est arrivé. Mais je sais
aussi que c'est le genre de
personne qui peuvent revenir des
et qui peuvent guérir et s'aider
mutuellement afin que tout le
monde puisse guérir. Je suis en
douleur avec vous, je suis en
deuil mais j'ai aussi beaucoup
d'espoir.
♪ ♪ ♪
- quelqu'un a dit il y a
plusieurs années que la douleur
vous suit. Et personne n'échappe
à cette douleur. Plus que jamais
notre province, notre région,
nos familles et nos villes sont
pleines de douleurs, de gens
brisés et notre confort, c'est
Jésus qui est venu nous guérir.
Il m'a envoyé pour guérir les
coeurs brisés, proclamer la
liberté pour les gens captifs.
Il est guéri en administrant le
confort divin. Nous tous, on ne
vit pas ça en ce moment mais
durant tout ce temps, il va nous
donner ce confort divin que l'on
cherche, indépendamment de la
douleur à l'intérieur de nous.
Le Christ est présenté comme un
compagnon sans faille, quand
personne n'est près de nous,
quand on est en douleur. Il est
avec nous toujours durant les
périodes difficiles, quand
personne n'est là, il est avec
nous d'une manière très spéciale
et proche de nous.
J'aimerais lire le verset de la
fin de la terre je vous appelle.
J'appelle à mesure que mon coeur
est en douleur. Amenez-moi au
point plus élevé pour moi-même.
♪ ♪ ♪
- la Nouvelle-Écosse, je vous ai
aimé depuis que j'ai un an et
que mon père était dans la GRC à
Halifax : on a passé cinq ans
sur Flamengo Drive.
Notre premier voyage était dans
les gestes pour que je puisse
leur montrer à quel point ces
boulets maritimes et que les
gens sont gentils. À s'inquiéter
de suite que je reviens
maintenant. Notre coeur est brié
pour vous. J'aurais aimé dire
quelque chose pour faire
disparaître la douleur mais je
sais que c'est pas possible.
Alors sachez que tout le Canada
vous aime.
On est en douleur avec vous.
- Bonsoir!
Je suis le conseillé municipal
pour le district neuf. Et aussi
un voisin et ami de plusieurs
des victimes de ce désastre.
Je peux seulement imaginer ce
que les gens ressentent.
Les gens qui ont perdu un être
aimé, la douleur, la colère et
la haine. Tout ça, c'est
justifié. Pour nous tous, je dis
que ces sentiments vont durer
longtemps et n'avons jamais
pleinement disparaître. Mais
avec le temps, la famille, les
amis, la douleur sera moindre.
Nous sommes tous en douleur avec
vous. Comme conseiller municipal
et ami, je suis ici si vous avez
besoin de moi, si vous avez
besoin de parler, besoin d'aide.
Je vous aime tous et j'espère
que vous allez pouvoir retrouver
votre vie telle qu'elle doit
être. Merci et que Dieu vous
bénisse.
♪ (Somewhere over the rainbow)
♪ ♪ ♪
- je veux juste dire que pour la
suite des choses, quand vous
essayez de revenir à une vie un
peu normale, on est ici derrière
vous, moi, nos familles, nos
communautés on est ici pour vous
aider. Je vais personnellement
si vous avez besoin de quelque
chose, et je veux dire tout ce
que je peux faire
personnellement pour vous aider,
vous pouvez m'appeler, je peux
vous aider à traverser des
difficultés.
- Bonjour tout le monde. Je suis
ici chez moi à Toronto mais bien
sûr, j'aurais aimé être avec
vous 12 ans Nouvelle-Écosse. La
Nouvelle-Écosse et mon chez moi,
c'est mon coeur. Je suis allé l-
bas à l'école primaire et à
l'école secondaire Halifax.
Quand les gens me demandent ou
si chez moi, chez moi c'est la
Nouvelle-Écosse. Et je suis
endeuillé, j'ai le coeur brisé.
Je suis loin mais je suis avec
vous dans mon coeur. Et pour tos
ceux qui ont souffert cette
grande perte, vous êtes dans mon
coeur. Je suis avec vous. Je
souffre avec vous et je vous
aime.
- Parce qu'on aime, on pleure.
Parfois les choses n'ont pas de
sens mon enfant. Parfois il n'y
a pas de réponse aux questions.
Parfois les choses sont
simplement sans compréhension.
Les gens meurent. Quand on a de
la douleur comme ça mon enfant,
qu'on a peur, qu'on est confus,
qu'on est souffrant, même si on
n'est pas ensemble, c'est
ensemble que nous pourrons
pleurer. Il y a beaucoup d'amour
parce qu'on aime, on pleure. Des
fois la douleur nous laissait
son souffle. Des fois la douleur
semble sans fin, profonde.
Parfois on ne trouve pas le
soleil. Parfois on aurait aimé
être endormi. Quand c'est dur,
quand ça fait mal, quand on a
peur, qu'on est souffrant au
confus mon enfant, même si on
est pas ensemble, ensemble
puissions-nous pleurer.
Rappelez-vous qu'il y a beaucoup
d'amour. Et parce qu'on aime,
nous pleurons.
J'aimerais avoir des réponses,
mon enfant. Prions que j'ai des
réponses. Il y a des choses
impossibles mon enfant que je ne
veux pas connaître et que je ne
peux pas expliquer. Quand on est
en deuil, en douleur, quand on a
peur, même si on n'est pas
ensemble, ensemble puissions-
nous pleurer. Rappelez-vous
qu'il y a tellement d'amour.
Parce qu'on aime, nous pleurons.
- Depuis samedi dernier, on a
souffert ici en Nouvelle-Écosse,
au Canada. Nous avons souffert
des événements tragiques qui ont
été douloureux, frustrant, des
parents, déprimant et beaucoup
de douleurs avec la COVID-19 en
plus : il semble que la douleur
est avec nous en 2020 et nous
savons que la partie la plus
difficile est encore devant
nous.
Les doutes peuvent venir et
disparaître mes nous ne sommes
pas désemparés. Le doute, c'est
pas un signe de faiblesse, et
qu'on est assailli. Nous devons
considérer la source, l'ennemi
de notre esprit, de notre coeur.
Une branche qui peut être
flexible ne cassera pas. On est
bienveillant et Dieu est avec
nous et va amener la justice.
Ces textes absolument
incroyables l'appui qu'on a
reçu, les appels et les
courriels, les prières sont bien
appréciées. Lundi soir, on a eu
un coucher de soleil qui nous
rappelle que Dieu est avec nous.
Prions continuellement pour la
guérison. Dieu est avec nous.
Nous sommes entre ses mains.
Quand j'essayais de comprendre
tout cela, c'était difficile
pour moi. Quand mon coeur est en
deuil et que mon esprit à
assailli, j'étais devant vous en
deuil. Et je suis toujours avec
vous. Le bon Dieu dit : je vous
ai par la main, vous me guidez.
Dieu me guide et après vous
amènerez dans votre esprit. Et
c'est notre espoir. Toute notre
ville, notre personnel, on vous
souhaite de l'espoir.
- Bonjour!
Les mots ne peuvent décrire la
douleur que nous ressentons à
mesure que nous sommes en deuil
de ces gens perdus dans cette
tragédie. Les nouvelles ont été
un vrai choc et ça continue
d'être un fait.
Nous devons vivre ce cauchemar
qui est devenu réalité. Au nom
du conseil municipal, je veux
étendre nos sympathies et
condoléances à toutes les
familles, amis et membres de la
communauté. Nos coeurs sont avec
vous tous. Nous voulons
reconnaître la constable de la
GRC qui a été tuée en exerçant
son devoir. Elle a été très
courageuse pour protéger sa
communauté.
Nous remercions les gens sur
leur première ligne. Nous
apprécions et reconnaissons tous
ceux qui ont travaillé pour nous
garder en sécurité.
Nos pensées et nos prières sont
avec vous. À mesure que vous
traversez cette situation très
difficile.
- Bonsoir, je suis Sidney
Peters, et au nom des chefs de
toutes les Premières Nations, je
veux exprimer mes condoléances à
tous ceux qui ont été affectés
par cette tragédie. Nous sommes
tous endeuillés par ce qui est
arrivé dans notre région. La
perte de ces individus ainsi que
leur famille et amis. Notre
communauté micmac est très
petite. Nous sommes très près
les uns des autres alors nous
comprenons comment une tragédie
comme ça peut toucher la
communauté et la nation au grand
complet. Nous voulons que les
gens de la région et des
secteurs avoisinants qu'on est
en deuil avec vous. Mais nous
traversons la crise ensemble.
Nous nous remémorant les
victimes et travaillant pour
être bienveillant, dans l'amour,
la lumière et occupons-nous les
uns des autres. En plus pour les
familles qui cherchent des
réponses, pour le coeur brisé,
que votre deuil soit affaibli
avec l'amour des êtres aimés.
- J'habite à Toronto mais je
suis de la Nouvelle-Écosse. J'ai
grandi à Pictou et je veux que
vous sachiez que je pense
beaucoup à vous tous dans ces
moments difficiles. Je vais
envoyer mon amour médical est à
tout le monde qui traverse cette
période très difficile. Je suis
très fié de ma province, je suis
fié de vous tous, je suis fié de
Pictou.
♪ ♪ ♪
- bon après-midi, je travaille
dans le soin et je veux parler à
vous tous comme membre de notre
communauté, localement,
nationalement et plus loin
encore. Et reconnaître les
condoléances les plus profondes
dans nos communautés. Quand on
voit les événements de la
dernière semaine, c'est
important de reconnaître que
nous mettons en place de
ressources pour le long terme et
on veut réitérer aux gens qu'on
sera ici pour continuer à
appuyer notre communauté.
Actuellement, on a une ligne
provinciale et on demande aux
gens d'appeler si vous avez
besoin d'aide, ce numéro va vous
acheminer vers les ressources
les plus appropriés. Nous
travaillons avec les écoles, les
centres de santé mentale, centre
palliatif pour être certain de
mettre des mesures en place. Je
veux juste renforcer le message
que même si c'est une période
très difficile, d'être en deuil
avec isolement et la pandémie,
vous n'êtes pas seul. On est ici
pour vous appuyer. Merci.
- La Nouvelle-Écosse, on vous
aime et on passe à vous. Notre
esprit, notre courage, tous les
Canadiens essaient d'être comme
vous. Quand nous passons du
temps dans votre province, les
enfants disent qu'ils ont de
retourner en Nouvelle-Écosse. On
vous aime.
- Ici Sidney Crosby, je suis de
la Nouvelle-Écosse, je veux vous
envoyer mes condoléances.
J'aimerais remercier tous les
gens en première ligne ainsi que
le personnel a fait face a
cette... ce cauchemar et nous a
gardé en sécurité. Nous sommes
tous ensemble comme toujours, en
aide à ceux qui en ont besoin.
- La GRC a été surprise comme le
reste de la planète. Nous sommes
avec le coeur brisé en sachant
qu'on a perdu un membre dans le
cours de son devoir en
protégeant la communauté. Elle
était aimée de plusieurs et elle
ne manquera beaucoup. Les
employés de la GRC, nous sommes
profondément attristés et nous
encourageons tous ceux qui
voudront faire un don à sa
famille à visiter notre site Web
- je veux envoyer de l'amour et
de la PMA communauté, mes
étudiants.
♪ ♪ ♪
♪ ♪ ♪♪ ♪ ♪
- Mon Dieu, je mets devant vous
tous ceux qui vivent dans la
douleur et le deuil sans
précédent. Mon Dieu, je sais que
la raison pourquoi la perte de
ces grandes c'est parce que
l'amour est tellement grand et
donc je vous remercie pour
l'appui qui a été reçu
dernièrement, de l'amour et de
la compassion. Et les
communautés expriment leur appui
et la grâce qui vient de vous,
votre grâce, la grâce que vous
avez toujours démontrée en
sacrifiant votre fils. J'envoie
ces gens dans vos bras et je
vous demande de veiller sur eux
ô mon Dieu et je prie au nom de
Jésus.
- Je suis Ana Almeida, je veux
envoyer mes profondes
condoléances aux familles des
victimes. Je vais envoyer mon
respect aux gens sur les
premières lignes. À mesure que
nous vivons deuil je suis
réconforté en sachant qu'on est
appuyé de la sorte avec tout
l'amour qui a été démontré à
date. Pour moi je sais que dans
cette heure difficile je me
tourne vers la musique, car je
ne peux m'exprimer avec des
mots. La Nouvelle-Écosse des
musiciens et des écrivains
incroyables qui utilisent des
mots pour nous donner et nous
guérir. C'est alors comme ça qui
me rend fier. La Nouvelle-Écosse
est chez moi. Le prochain
artiste, c'est pas juste un
musicien, c'est un ami.
Bonjour, mon nom est Charlie, je
vais envoyer mes sympathies et
condoléances aux familles et aux
amis des gens disparus. La
dernière fin de semaine. Je veux
que tout le monde sache qu'on
est uni et qu'on est en deuil
avec vous, en partage notre
douleur et ce soir, j'envoie la
musique directement de mon coeur
et j'espère que ça touchera
votre coeur. Cette chanson
s'appelle Refuse to fear.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Bonjour, comme plusieurs
d'entre vous, mes chers
concitoyens, je suis à la maison
et je sais de comprendre les
événements tragiques qui ont eu
lieu la semaine dernière. Il n'y
a pas de mots. Pour ceux qui
sont en deuil, sachez que vous
êtes dans mon coeur, mes prière,
et nous sommes tous avec vous.
Et ça peut sembler très
difficile et très sombre, sachez
que. Que Dieu vous bénisse.
- Les mots ne peuvent exprimer
mon coeur est en deuil, mon coer
est brisé. J'aurais aimé être
avec moi personne pour vous
prendre dans mes bras, pour vous
ensevelir d'amour et vous dire
que je vous aime. Vous êtes pas
seul et je veux amener l'amour
du bon Dieu avoue mais
maintenant, tout ce que je peux
faire, c'est offrir cette prière
au bon Dieu. Nous sommes devant
vous pour vous, au bon Dieu, je
m'élève dans la prière avec
toutes les personnes qui ont
vécu la douleur et la
dévastation avec cet acte de
violence dans nos communautés.
Nous nous remémorant ceux qui
ont perdu la vie sans raison et
nous remerciant le bon Dieu pour
la vie qui a été donnée par ces
gens. Nous prions pour que vous
aimeriez l'histoire de ces gens.
Et la mémoire de ces gens. Et
nous les tenons dans notre coeur
et nous vous demandons mon Dieu
de le prendre dans vos bras,
toutes les familles qui ont été
changées à jamais par la douleur
et consoler ses familles,
réconforté, nous les tenons dans
notre coeur, les collègues, amis
et membres de la communauté,
rassembler ces gens, ramenez-les
dans votre cas, dans la force du
bon Dieu. La guérison après le
trauma de la dévastation qui est
arrivée et qu'il ait le courage
de faire face à la suite des
choses.
- Je suis fondatrice d'une
petite compagnie à Truro,
quelqu'un qui vient de la région
avec c'est arrivé la semaine
dernière, je suis sans mots.
C'est difficile à comprendre,
quelqu'un qui a fait quelque
chose de si tragique, je me suis
engagé à aider les familles à
traverser toute cette période
difficile avec dedans. C'est
maintenant le temps de se
rassembler, à travers le Canada,
parce que nous sommes ensemble
et nous serons faire ensemble.
- Bonjour, je vais envoyer de
l'amour, de la force àous ceux
qui sont touchés et à toutes nos
familles et amis et voisins,
membre de la communauté qu'on a
perdue, vous ne manquez, on vous
aime et c'est bien de se
rappeler qu'elle meilleure jour
de notre vie et demain. Alors
pourquoi attendre demain pour
vivre notre meilleure vie.
Rappelle qu'un action d'amour
vaut une vie pour quelqu'un
d'autre. Vous me manquez, je
vous aime.
♪ ♪ ♪
- d'une certaine façon les
choses sont plus faciles avec le
temps. C'est toujours le cas,
les humains sont très
brésiliens. Pour ces femmes et
ça va être plus difficile à
mesure que l'impact, va
s'imprégner. On va mettre un
lien pour les familles pour les
dons, pour vous rappeler que si
c'est arrivé avoue directement
ou indirectement, c'est correct
d'être triste, vos sentiments
peuvent changer. C'est correct
aussi. Mais promettez-moi que
vous allez chercher de l'aide si
c'est nécessaire, il y a
plusieurs options que vous
verrez sur notre site.
♪ ♪ ♪
(Amazing Grace à la cornemuse)
- c'est un hommage rempli
d'émotions. Des moments de
silence, des gestes de
solidarité ont eu lieu un peu
partout au pays en mémoire des
victimes. La douleur en laissant
est toujours vive et le restera
pour un bon moment. À travers
tout ça, il y a l'enquête qui se
poursuit. Je vous signale
d'ailleurs qu'un dossier complet
qui comprend une majorité mais
disponible sur le Radio-
Canada.ca/nouvelleecossedeuil
c'est tout pour cette émission
spéciale, ici Karine Godin à
Moncton, je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée. Bonsoir.
♪ ♪ ♪